so you got to hear this Robin we we made
a decision to send Sal to that
professional job interviewer okay
fortune 500 company yeah so she's a
person who interviews people for a
living for their jobs and we set this
out go to you know go go in and apply
for a job pretend Howard no longer works
sal is so [ __ ] he will never get
another job
Sal just said he doesn't want to hear
this why don't you want to hear it well
just according to your take on it
already I'm extremely embarrassed now if
you ask me seriously do I think I did
well yes I did but your interpretation
makes my stomach turn this has to be the
first job interview I've ever heard in
history where a guide mentions piss porn
what did ya what I mean I did have you
specifically done anything that would
make them think that you're a pervert no
we discussed on-air like our personal
the things like we've loved as far as
like there's a lot of pornography that's
been discussed on the show so like we
might talk about the particular types of
pornography we like and I've discussed
in the past I've like it's called piss
porn you know like and you know poppy in
Germany and I've discussed that and
stuff she's dialing the police okay
first of all you know women find piss
porn absolutely disgusting I mean you
could have mentioned a worse type of
porn if you I mean first of all don't
mention porn but this is the best one so
she says to him what would people who
like him the least what would they say
about you at work and there's a way to
answer questions at a job interview
where you go like yeah you know people
at work say I work too hard and you know
it ruins it for them that's how you
answer that yes al if you think about
the person that likes you the least what
do you think they would say about you
I'll probably like I'm a racist they
would say they would probably say I'm a
pervert they would say I'm a creep they
would say that I'm crazy they would say
that I'm an idiot why would they say
those
because they only hear what I say you
know people might judge me because and
that's fine because they only know what
they hear so if somebody captures three
minutes of me talking about a particular
fetish I like you know sexual fetish
they might just join in on that and
judge me and label me and that's it it's
signed sealed and delivered
now you understand the difference
between a therapy session and a job
interview right I guarantee you tan mom
could get a job over you yeah you know
without hearing that back you absolutely
right I can't believe I said those
things I mean I was just so focused on
being honest and I always think that if
you're not honest you come off as
disingenuous and people can read that so
I I thought I did the best that I could
do can I just point out one other thing
cause it was so great he said all those
things about him and she goes why would
people say that about you and I thought
he's gonna go well things get
misinterpreted and his exact sentence
was they listen to the words that come
out they say they hear me maybe that's
where Robin lamps so hard you can almost
not hear Sal anymore I don't know why I
made a left turn from racist to sexual
fetish that is a little odd
now that I hear I could have put the
brakes on just the idiot and racist
stuff idiot and racist
Chow by the way I'm all for honesty but
you can select what you want to talk
about that you want more this is the
best sal had a really hard time with the
last and easiest question there's a
layup she gave him a layup why should I
hire you and Sal had a really really
hard time so if you had to summarize it
why should I hire you let me ask you why
should you hire me no it doesn't work
that way
why should you hire me
it's kind of an odd question because I
would think at this point you would know
if you want to hire me or not I think
I've said enough I do but I want to see
how well you can summarize why you
believe that I should hire you well I
believe you should hire me because I'm
dedicated I work hard I'm a team player
I believe in synchronicity because I
love what I do and because I'm sincerely
dedicated and I'm hard on myself and I
believe in being a team player [ __ ]
unbelievable right it's amazing when you
said you were going to play some answers
I couldn't imagine they could be this
off the mark he's he's a disaster
awesome Sal like no one has ever done a
worst job interview